Computer security is an absolutely
fascinating field. It's a lot of fun to
work on, and it's a problem that's only
getting worse as time goes by
because more of our data is available
online. Hello, my name is Dan Boneh. I'm a professor of Computer
Science and Electrical Engineering here at
Stanford University. I'm also co-director
of the Computer Security Lab. And I teach
many courses in computer security, all of
which count towards the Cybersecurity
Graduate Certificate. Computer security is an
extremely important area for our graduates to be familiar with. When they build software out in
the real world, it's absolutely vital that
they understand the security impacts of
everything they write.
The industry is kinda desperate for talent
in computer security, it's absolutely
fundamental and crucial part of computer
security education. And we take it very
seriously when we teach our class.
We're at the heart of Silicon Valley
where all these companies are around us. When
we want to talk about computer security
with Google or with Facebook it's real easy
to just get in the car and go meet with, with our colleagues in those companies. I think the
importance of computer security has kind
of shot up in the last couple of years
tremendously.
There are constantly attacks on computer
systems. We all hear about breaches of data theft, IP theft all
happening on a daily basis.
All of that is really focused
everybody's attention on computer
security, and as a result there is a lot of
interest.
Everybody wants to learn computer
security- we cannot graduate students
fast enough!
The Graduates of the Cybersecurity Graduate program all go work in industry and
develop products. Often they work as
program managers, developers they write a
lot of code that actually ships in
products. Upon successful completion of
four courses you will receive your
Stanford Certificate. Stanford is
actively working to address the world's
cybersecurity needs. It's an exciting time to
study with us and gain vital skills
needed for today's cyber workforce.